طيب سالنا الناس منير ما رايك بالارتفاع
الكبير في تحديد الوقت بدل الضائع في
المونديال 20 22 نسمع ونرجع
[موسيقى]
90 دقيقه يعني ايا كان الوقت اللي بيضيع
على الاوت او الجود او الاستهتار او
البساطه هم بيقدروا يوفروا الكلام ده فعلا
ال 90 دقيقه فانا شايف ان هم مهما كانت
المده يحسبوها ده افضل طبعا للفرقتين عشان
ما يبقاش في احد مضبوط المونديال انا
متاكد انها تنجح لان همم طبيعه المنتخبات
اللي هي بتلعب اصلا معظمها منتخبات
اوروبيه وامريكا اللاتينيه فبالتالي هتنجح
يعني مش شايف انها تبقى فيها اي مشكله
خالص والله هنا شايف ان ده احسن همم بحيث
ان يعني موضوع تضيع وقت بقى خلاص ما فيش
اي احد مثلا يخطف جون ويقعد بعيد الماتش
عمال يضيع وقت ويقعد يتصاب والحاجات اللي
بتحصل ليه فيعني انا شايف ان ده هيبقى
مفيد اكتر لمتعه الكوره ما فيش مشكله من
زياده الوقت يعني 10 دقائق ربع ساعه بس كل
واحد ياخذ حقه
[موسيقى]
لا هو بيدي بس مش للدرجه دي يعني لو لو
بالضبط ابقى قل لي دقيقه دقيقتين بتاع لكن
هو كفر شويه
على الاقل والله الولد ضيع اللي بيتحاسب
يعني المفروض
تقع كثيره وبتحس باربع دقائق ثلاث دقائق
والكلام ده ما ينفعش والله هو نظام جديد
الدوريات الباقيه هو المفروض ان هو كويس
اللي جنب برده جنب ان انت بتدي العداله
الكامله الفرق
بتاعه كامل نفس الوقت الكوره بحيث ان انت
ايه يعني مثلا انا رحت تحتفل
مثلا او الكوره خرجت قوي